okay that's my favorite line like
Larry's say up the carriage he said he
can't see check please you got a check
please uh check please
he said he once said now everybody say
that's except me so now I won't say it
but that is you won't get narrow in here
to to say it yeah well that was
disturbing yeah I speak at fluent
captain and that's how can't say that
phrase I'm not gonna say now so yeah
this is uh : tell Jacob video-makers
okay this is video-makers yeah it's
pretty much just a fun little episode
where they read the warning before the
movie and they think that because it's
there they actually can't watch the
movie which the way YouTube is taking
some things off there might be some
truth to that but yeah so pretty much
they're gonna go and make their own film
and they just shoot all the stuff they
have BMO shoot everything and at the
very end they have this big disagreement
on whether and I should be an action
film or romantic comedy and I just well
it's they're both so bad too but
particularly the romantic comedy cuz I
love Jake is always like he just he has
the punch line but he has no setup so
yeah at the end people just sings a song
it's like stop fighting they're like
okay and then one of them says what one
of them says the end yeah they say the
end you're you're good
nice data that's it done that was the
word those get the phrases give me loud
at the end it's just funny mm-hmm yeah
he's gonna hurt me while he's after this
be logged um but it's it was my I I like
the stuff that shows how movies may
actually it might be a lot of American
movie or see that when it's not the one
where they're making the horror movie
called Kovan I think that's why it's
called oh my god it's like a reaiiy drew
what I saw it I thought it was actually
symmetry like I could believe these
people sadly met that guy - oh did you
hear is he's really nice I will say that
he owes on school the then one the
actual director yeah his friend yeah
really nice guy that's cool no I saw
that oh just like the whole way through
I thought was like a witch more like a
Christopher gasps movie there's
something like that like no no this is
like Kevin O'Hara's gonna come out and
you know give either they're all actors
right but actually Jory put it best she
said like she felt it was like the true
work of the devil because it's terrible
but you just had to keep walking and you
kept watching not the episode American
movie but um but yeah so III like stuff
that shows the making of a film or just
video whatever this is and really quick
question considering you know you guys
have been making movies for a long time
has in the beginning when they're first
making it they sued a whole bunch of
stuff and they're like while they're
shooting it they're like this is awesome
this is great then they finally watch it
they're like wow this is this kind of
blah did that ever has that ever
happened to you oh yeah there's I mean
you get a little better and figuring out
okay what you don't like when we start
off it's like yeah it's all your just
think it's all gonna be incredible of
that what yet you see it you're like ooh
yeah we need a little bit more maybe a
little bit more selective of what we
shoot and what we don't and what we edit
out and stuff um but yeah and I think
that's that's part of the fun and I like
the idea like it's sort of like Edward
how he always carried around that big
well was that called idea to megaphone
yeah and the megaphone but there's no
reason for the prices right here they'll
still be talking through they just like
the idea of having a megaphone okay I
love it when they have was the slime
princess well yeah they telling her the
set up is great to have her yeah Wayne -
so we got that vine over the crocodiles
and then land on the ground ready and
going you know what's gonna happen you
know she's gonna just fall in to get
even by the crocodiles but it's the fact
that she land in the water and the way
they all lived like that they didn't
just dive into why I mean they jump out
it ends on the water and it's just so
well animated
um so that cracked me up uh and yeah the
only other thing I noticed about this
particularly in the opening I thought
was very interesting you know they start
their movie night and everyone
everyone's in like their hoodies and you
know whatever street clothes and so I
thought what the platy trunks have like
a hoodie or something like that but but
something I realize watching this is
that a Finn and Jake don't have any real
guy friends yeah yeah I mean like not
even a token guy they're I mean they're
just all all girls which I thought was
kind of insurance a peppermint Butler
you know he shows up later though okay
yeah all the armed with a shoe up a
layer but when the movie night actually
starts yeah there's like no guys at all
there's no boys so uh I thought that was
candy like I said just no not not even
like a Tokyo hot in there not like just
a girl wearing a moustache just saw I'm
a boy um again sick anytime a joke bombs
I'm just gonna say I'm sick so um yeah I
liked it I like I like anything that
shows like I said just the making of a
video and stuff like a Eva viz in a
cartoon so uh yeah but you I really like
the ending I mean it's funny it's funny
it's funny and this is one of those
where to me it was just a nice little
touching moment where BMO is BMO's in a
sense the center of everything that's
going on you know he's the one that sees
everything going on behind the camera
considering well he is the camera and
mm-hmm
you know when you're making a movie or
whatnot you know no one really knows
what's going on behind the scenes they
only see the finalized product and I
love how BMO just kind of said you know
what no I'm not making me either or you
guys need to stop this stupid fighting
and I'm gonna add it together the best
scenes that I filmed and the best build
was just them helping each other in all
of that and I felt it I found it really
really touching that that's what BMO
picked hmm and that BMO sang to them
saying you know basically like you guys
are idiots for fighting over something
so minor because everyone does that it's
some stupid thing where you know it's
like I sit down on the couch and I bump
you a bit and you're like god stop it
what the hell you know it's so minor and
so silly but everyone takes these things
and beeps um
to something huge when it comes down to
it and it should just be you know
friendship I will say if you do bump it
to me again I will crucify you I'm just
saying right now upside down on my wall
yes just that's apparently where that
happened right right here or did happen
like in Jerusalem you know I'm just
gonna go away please